anyways yeah I would say feminists girls
that like are super only fans club like
that sort of thing and
um
whales number one is whales do you know
why they hate you like do you do you
because I my perception like the way I
feel about it is that they hate you
because you're saying stuff there's
truth to it if there wasn't truth to
what you were saying they wouldn't hate
you they would just be like oh who cares
yeah there's truth to it and also it
makes them reflect on their own choices
so now if you're talking about how
female promiscuity is not empowering and
they've been promiscuous and they bought
the story that that was somehow
empowering they're listening to you and
they're like we gotta shut her up see
and here's the thing a lot of times we
have this narrative like oh they bought
the story when they're young I don't
really believe that I think deep down on
an innate level we all know because
what's the first thing that girls call
each other when we're mad you're a hoe
why are you saying that if it's a good
thing I feel like sometimes that's a
cop-out that women use well they'll be
like oh I bought it and I'm like did you
did so you don't think that women bought
the story then why did they do it if
they didn't buy the story they just
wanted no consequences and like honestly
there really aren't a like even I mean
you could you're a generation older but
I asked my mom I'm like do the hoes get
married too she said yeah so at the end
of the day there's really not a lot of
consequences for any of it see I think
they have to have bought the story to an
extent because there's too many of them
that aren't comfortable being
promiscuous like they'll do it but they
go home they're miserable they cry about
it they call their friends they're mad
yeah they're mad the guy didn't call
them back they're expecting that guy to
behave like a boyfriend when it was
really clearly just to hook up so
they're so upset about it that they're
then trying to map out with their friend
on the phone like why doesn't he like me
because it's like they bought the story
that somehow they were going to be
promiscuous and it was going to feel
good and they were going to get what
they wanted or something beneficial for
them out of that situation and they
don't they're all miserable I think like
there's a hesitance to point out that a
lot of women who followed feminist
advice they're just so unhappy they
don't reflect like they're promiscuous
but unhappy they're on birth control
unhappy they're climbing the corporate
ladder unhappy why why no
self-reflection in the process do you
think
um
I I just kind of have a different view
on it I just what's your take I just
think they liked the party life I just
think it was fun you know what I mean
like okay maybe how many girls do you
really know that are really climbing the
corporate ladder I mean you maybe you
think you lived in New York right maybe
you knew more of them but I'm like most
girls I know just have average jobs and
most girls in general have average jobs
they're not climbing anything I mean I
know a lot of girls that are trying that
are trying to compete with men like in
the cities and I grew up with a lot of
them that were like I want to be the
manager I want to be the CEO I want to
be like that's that's a sign that I've
been successful in life and they they
forward having children for a really
long time in order to do that so I think
they exist and they're you know this is
just I'm just saying by and large the
average salary is like 35
000 a year for women so like by and
large women aren't climbing the
corporate ladder like there are some
right maybe like 10 15 but I would say
like by and large it's more just like it
was fun so they want to have fun yeah
you you believe that women modern women
are deriving enjoyment from that
pro-promiscuity structure there you
believe they're not unhappy at that no I
think they're unhappy like how do I put
it when the consequences happen so like
when they sleep with a bunch of people
and then like everyone finds out and
they're like oh [ __ ] you know now but do
I think like to start yeah they're
having fun and then you know life
catches up to you it's kind of like you
eat 10 cheeseburgers every time you eat
the cheeseburger it's fun you're happy
but then you're 300 pounds Rebecca yeah
um so that's how I see it yeah see I
don't think they're having fun I think
they're programmed little robots I think
they're largely miserable and I think
they they were they can't change because
they don't they've been told that that's
what they should be doing it's crazy
though you look at like college girls
coming out today some of these body
counts how do you come out of college 15
20 people you're telling me I mean did
you study girlfriend did you do what did
you do like I don't understand where
that kind of time comes from honestly oh
my God no oh my gosh the girl on my show
the one who I was like okay this is I'm
gonna tell you this story okay I'm sorry
I'm all over the place she may give the
names away
look at Amy and and she comes on my show
and she's she okay I did we're talking a
show about body count right how many
bodies is too many body questions like
that I don't usually the only time I ask
people their body count is when I say is
body count important and they say no and
then I say then what's your body count
but the point isn't to get their body
count the point is to show it's
important right because otherwise
everyone would just be like this you
know so um on this show as a joke I was
like what's he has his body count and I
said haha you don't have to say it's
okay like I was kidding she's all this
pro-sex girl so she's like oh I'll say
it to get rid of the stigma are you sure
she says yes okay go ahead go ahead this
girl threatens to sue me because she
said her body count on live
that's ridiculous why did you say it so
litigious people oh my God sex positive
that's another that's a word that just
popped into my head I don't do you watch
any of this like The Bachelorette or any
of that stuff you watch any of those
shows oh my gosh are they used to my
team used to watch it in college but I
would get so bored and then I would just
give my opinion like no imagine watching
The Bachelorette with me giving my
opinions
they stopped inviting me I said they're
like they're like pearls like we don't
care like if you think it's stupid
um but I actually I started watching the
Recaps and I liked those better there's
like so this is a channel called
Bachelor fan takes so sometimes I'll
watch the Recaps of Seasons so it's
interesting to watch because if you
especially if you're in this area and
you're doing this kind of content it's
interesting to watch first of all if you
go to older episodes you can see like
how much male female Dynamics have
changed even in terms of what's
presented to the public in the last like
15 years much more traditional like if
you looked at you know some of the First
episodes versus what you see now but
there was a girl on it recently a couple
of seasons ago and she was sex positive
she actually showed up and the first
thing that she did was pull out a dildo
Katie Katie Thurston and she was like
and these women are like kind of
horrified that guys would care about
body count like the guys get to the end
and they say like hey if you're sleeping
with a bunch of girls I can't do this
like you're already you're supposed to
be in love with me and the girls are
like this is outrageous and the audience
loves what the girls are saying they
love it because they're like yeah girl
power in the meantime I'm sitting there
like if he really loves you and you're
saying you love him you shouldn't be
able to go into the next room and sleep
with somebody else honey something's
broken inside oh my oh you're talking
about Hannah brown or whatever oh yes
when she slept with the yeah I'm like
what guy wants to produce her
you want to marry a girl that's proposed
to a girl that slept with another dude
three days before three days before
would you sign up for that Deli you
going down the aisle or no no no no
leave me out of this but seriously how
do you even how do you I mean I don't
understand what's so broken see what
bothers me is I feel like there's
something broken in women because and I
keep going back to like it's not natural
for us to behave this way I don't feel
like it's natural for women to behave
this way and like what is broken that
you can't even understand now that a guy
cares that three days ago you're
sleeping with someone else and now
you're in his bed that's nasty yeah I I
do feel like hypergamy is natural like
women like like monkey branching and
dating up that's when I went to an art
museum and there's paintings of girls
being hypergamous
red pill lens on an on a museum walk
yeah yeah Ally took me she took a new
Museum and she was showing me oh my gosh
these girls have always been the same so
if you get married what do you want that
marriage to look like oh um as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible